por tierra por aire y por mar la
comunidad internacional intensificó las
evacuaciones de los ciudadanos y
personal diplomático que permanecía en
Sudán en complejas operaciones los
países intervinieron para sacar a sus
ciudadanos del territorio azotado por un
conflicto interno entre las facciones
militares el jefe diplomático de la
Unión Europea del josep borrell destacó
el trabajo de los países del bloque
operation
ha sido una operación compleja y exitosa
en primer lugar 21 funcionarios del
personal de la Unión Europea ya están en
Europa y muchos más ciudadanos de la
Unión Europea y otros ya están fuera de
Sudán son más de mil personas que ya
están seguras
autosudán
Quiero agradecer especialmente a Francia
por evacuar a nuestra gente y Quiero
agradecer los esfuerzos conjuntos de
muchos países que sacaron a sus
nacionales pero también a todos los
nacionales que pudieron elegir
las evacuaciones que incluyen la
ciudadana sudaneses que huyen hacia
países vecinos como Egipto se
completaron casi sin incidentes un
convoy francés fue atacado por un
tirador del ejército regular mientras
era escoltado por paramilitares y dejó
un civilidad algunos evacuados han
llegado a sus países de origen pero la
mayoría fue trasladada a shibuty un
pequeño territorio de la región que
alberga instalaciones militares
extranjeras
[Música]
gracias a Dios estoy a salvo eso es lo
principal mi familia está a salvo me
gustaría agradecer a las fuerzas
especiales de Francia por la increíble
misión no es fácil evacuar tus propios
ciudadanos y a los ciudadanos de otras
nacionalidades
nunca vio un plan tan eficiente y
brillante no soy militar Pero esto fue
ejecutado a la perfección puede ver que
ninguna vida se perdió todo el mundo
está a salvo
Sudán transito en la violenta situación
entre el ejército y el grupo paramilitar
o fuerzas de apoyo rápido reiterados
pactos para detener el fuego han sido
violados en los últimos días y genera
preocupación no solo en países vecinos
que empiezan a sentir las secuelas del
conflicto sino también en la comunidad
internacional